welcome back to new rockstars I'm Erik
Bosse and our ongoing breakdown to the
infinity saga during this quarantine
period that's just stumbled upon its
first infinity stone and while we now
know how each of these rainbow god rocks
down their way to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and then how they were later
used multiple times and you've got awful
things that we haven't fully appreciated
the implications of these little turds
remain Nuggets a mystery not only do
alternate versions of them still exist
in alternate timelines if the MCU who
ever wants to visit them we still don't
know where most of them were in the eons
prior to when we first laid eyes on them
and in the way that the space stones
backstory gave us the origin of Captain
Marvel other's stones backstories appear
to be the basis of upcoming MCU phase 4
titles they should have been delayed but
not forever cancelled so let's look
backwards to breakdown the origin of
each Infinity stone and what those
origins could tell us about phase board
and let us start with a stone Thanos
started with an infinity war of the
power stone in the first guardians of
the galaxy film the collector explained
the origins of all the Infinity stones
dating back to the Big Bang before
creation itself there were 16 dramatic
then the universe exploded into
existence and the remnants of these
systems were forged into concentrated
ingots infinity stone the collector
pointed to one ancient user of the Power
Stone a celestial blingy Isan the
searcher Isan used it to wipe out an
entire civilization and then later the
collector explained how an unnamed group
attempted to wield the Power Stone
collectively but they were all destroyed
and this resulted in it getting encased
in the orbit so presumably Isan somehow
lost the power stone he could have been
defeated in battle or maybe he willingly
gave up the stone Isan is one of two
living Celestials we've seen in
existence so far in the MCU along with
ego Peter Quill's father worth noting
that another Marvel Comics star Lords
father isn't ego but another character
named Jason son of Emperor Isan FMC
wants to keep that lineage intact ego
could be the son of Isan in the MCU and
maybe it was pinko who stole the power
stone from his father's dead hands so
what happened to ego
well ego claimed to have no memory
before his spontaneous existence as a
brain floating in space I don't know
where I came from
exactly first thing I remember is
flickering adrift in the cosmos utterly
and entirely alone one theory that I
really like is that egos adrift brain
came from the giant severed celestial
head of nowhere now in the Marvel Comics
that celestial was decapitated by the
symbiote deity no using all black the
necro sword these same sword carried by
gore the god butcher the character
rumored to be played by Christian Bale
in Thor love and thunder so we played
see a backstory where the ancient sword
that Thor battles with Stormbreaker all
black the Necker sword was used in some
ancient past to slay ego in this
previous celestial form and send the
power stone into the hands of these
other idiots and then later found by
egos son asan's grandson who's a
star-lord mask actually kind of looks
like a son celestial armor what do you
think about it it just was like to
circle eye holes another infinity stone
whose origin could be detailed in Thor
love and thunder is the one that's
gotten the most screen time so far in
the MCU this space stone Odin hid space
stone and nor
away in the tenth century but Ragnarok
suggested an earlier history on Asgard
with hello recognizing the tesseract
let's go fab we don't know exactly how
the space don't ended up and Asgardian
hands to begin with isn't it an
interesting coincidence that the
Asgardians have the unique power of the
Bifrost allowing teleportation anywhere
in the universe which is also the power
provided by the space stone I know I
know in comics lore the space stone the
Bifrost are different things I'm just
saying I could definitely see the MCU
retconning them into having these same
source of power
Thor's Stormbreaker also has the power
of the Bifrost perhaps that will be
explored along with the other mysteries
of the odinforce as they pass along to
Jane Foster and Thor xi under it ain't
always easy to keep these daily doses of
distraction coming at you from the blue
dungeon mark - sometimes I like to fall
asleep in here and it's very
disorienting to wake up and just see all
blue anyway the best way for me to get
an extra energy boost is with a bang
energy and thanks to bang energy for
sponsoring this video every can of bang
is 16 ounces that's right there's no
wimpy 12 ounce cans here it contains 300
milligrams of caffeine it's sugar-free
and has zero calories yet it tastes
great whoo there are over 20 different
flavors to choose from this one is
birthday cake bash it's a my birthday
this week because I'm not allowed to
have a party I'm celebrating it with
bang thanks for that happy birthday
flavor bang check out bang on Instagram
you can get 25% off your order at bang -
energy calm when you use the code in New
York starts 25 another birthday kiss
there you can buy cans bang energy
including their sweet tea kiyo coffee
flavors and birthday cake - you can also
get clothing fitness supplements all
kinds of stuff to be your best bang self
thanks again a bang energy for
sponsoring this video get 25% off at
bang - energy comm using the code at new
rock stars 25 and follow the inventor of
bang on instagram at bang energy dot CEO
another infinity stone with Asgardian
history is the reality stone Thor the
dark world opened with a prologue
explaining the ancient history of the
Dark Elves and Malekith who in 2988 BC
sought to exploit the convergence of the
nine realms to warp all of reality and a
darkness stick such evil was possible
through the power of the ether
an ancient force of infinite destruction
Malekith turned the reality stone into
the liquid sludge ether form after
finding that stone buried deep in the
bedrock of svartalfheim perhaps it
crashed there after the big bang and
then after Malekith attempt Odin's
father Bor confiscated the ether and hit
it on Asgard
now the next Infinity stone with
mysterious origins is the time stone
from what we know the time stone has
been in the possession of the masters of
mystic arts contained in the eye of
agamotto
Agra moto was an ancient sorcerer who
forbade usage of his eyen necklace
though later Cagliostro was permitted to
study the artifact and he inscribed all
the spells in his slam book but that
doesn't mean the time stone has always
been on earth the post-credits scene of
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 revealed a
group of Ravagers with kruger alum who's
a sorcerer using similar spells as dr.
strange and his other buddies and that's
because in the comics Krueger is
sorcerer supreme in an alternate future
by the name Cu he presumably belongs to
the same network of mystic warriors a
network that could expand far into the
galaxy
so the time stone could have fallen into
the hands of other extraterrestrial
mystics in ancient times and then passed
along until he got into Agra motos hands
that's history we could see explored in
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 or Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
now on to the mind stone which got its
MCU introduction and Loki's scepter in
the Avengers though it's debated whether
Loki or Thanos knew the sceptre
contained an infinity stone like an end
game Gamora nebula we're saying that a
Power Stone was the first one he found
in 2014 but whether or not they
announced new it's the mine stone was
the first stone in his possession that
we know about he handed it off to Loki
in the scepter to attack earth for the
tesseract in 2012 they announced late
scepter sometime during his past warpath
where he in this story army what planet
to planet killing half of everything
they found now it is worth noting that
Thanos is an eternal technically he has
a deviant gene but Marvel's upcoming the
eternal seems like it's gonna answer a
lot of these questions the Eternals were
created by the Celestials such tools
like Isan and ego but actually there's a
whole bunch of them and that history
could be the thing that unites the
origins of all of these things the
guardians of the galaxy Thanos the
Asgardians the Infinity stones maybe
even the mutants of Earth our last stone
that we haven't talked about is the soul
stone
of course requires a blood sacrifice and
for me er which nebula described in an
interesting way an endgame the Dominion
of death at the very center of celestial
existence
so let's do existence uh-huh as the
keeper of the soul stone red skull
possessed some divine wisdom over
people's parentage they don't have Ivan
Lintin son of Edith perhaps the Eternals
movie will reveal how these Celestials
encoded the Infinity stones with a
certain genealogy and the reason the
soul stone knew Thanos his father is
because it's connected to as nebula
stated celestial existence an existence
that could include the mysterious origin
of ego possibly son of the stone wielder
Isan which have been any stone are you
most curious to learn the origin of join
our watch alongs of the Infinity Saga
films on disk or by becoming a patron at
patreon.com slash new rock stars comment
below with your thoughts follow me on
instagram twitter @ EA vas followed new
rock stars and subscribe for breakdowns
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]